[Music]
hi welcome to next
in the session I am going to walk you
through building a serverless event
driven web app in under 10 minutes
my name is Prashant and I am a developer
Advocate with Google Cloud
in the next few minutes we will look at
what an even driven architecture is and
what are the benefits of using
serverless we will then Define a sample
scenario which we will design using
these principles then we will actually
build a working application before
concluding this session first let us
look at what is an event driven
architecture and why do we need this
more and more organizations are moving
out of monolith application architecture
towards microservices intending to
simplify their architecture and reduce
the total cost of ownership however as
the application grows bigger their
request driven microservice applications
starts looking like a spider web of
services calling each other
it could end up looking like a
decentralized monolith due to the hard
buyer dependencies between these
services
the application complexity starts
increasing and maintaining applications
becomes harder and harder with each new
service that you add because you need to
integrate with both upstream and
downstream services
what can we do to simplify the
application architecture and move faster
that's where even driven architecture
comes into the picture this is an
architectural pattern which allows your
applications or services to communicate
with each other asynchronously through
the means of events which typically
signify completion of a process it
allows you to scale faster because when
you add new Services you don't have to
think a lot about your Downstream or
Upstream services and hence reducing
code changes and dependencies
it also avoids performance bottlenecks
from slower Downstream Services as the
Upstream service can decouple itself
from the downstream dependencies by
firing an event and forgetting about it
now that we have seen how an even driven
architecture could help us to build
faster let us look at why serverless
when you manage your own infrastructure
along with building your applications
you will need to handle all the aspects
including the physical aspects of
hardware and connectivity to the
operational aspects of scaling and
managing security
in the serverless or a fully managed
environment you can abstract away the
infrastructure and operations aspect
such as managing and provisioning
servers fully managed also means
scalability and scaling down to zero so
when your app has no traffic you are not
charged you can focus on building and
monitoring your business logic while
Google manages the infrastructure what
this means is you as a developer can
spend more time coding and don't need to
spend time managing infrastructure some
of the benefits you gain by using
serverless are accelerate time to Market
by reducing setup effort and hence
increased velocity
Simplicity by enabling developers with
easy onboarding and self-service
Standing Up application environments
ensuring service availability with high
elasticity multi-region deploys and
Global load balancing reduce risk to
your company by moving higher up the
stack with built-in security and
operations
let us now pen down a simple use case
and see how one could actually use
serverless and even driven architecture
to build out an application
this is my sample use case as a
developer I want to build an application
that searches the Twitter public feed
for tweets on burden attempts calculates
the scores and displays the scores in a
publicly available leaderboard web app
for those not familiar with World which
is a free to play Word game a typical
round is one where I try to guess the
hidden word of the day and as few
attempts as possible it is common for
players to tweet out the number of
attempts that they took to solve a game
it is this tweet that we are looking for
and we will provide a score based on the
number of attempts taken
I would then build out the application
in this manner in order to search for
the tweets on Twitter we would have to
first authenticate the Twitter apis and
make a free text search query to
retrieve the search results the Twitter
API Returns the results in batches so we
will need to call the API multiple times
and consolidate the results since it is
a free text search we'll have to filter
relevant results essentially I'm looking
for the tweets which have the attempt
numbers
we will have to repeat this entire thing
periodically to fetch new tweets
calculate scores and save them to the
database we might want to build a
leaderboard in different formats example
order by all-time top scores or order by
best average score per user or show the
best scores in each round as you can see
this started as a straightforward and
simple requirement however when we start
thinking about the moving parts then we
see that the architecture gets a little
complex
enough talk let's dive in and build out
the sample application and identify
which Google Cloud products we will use
as we build this out
let's jump into the Google Cloud console
so here I am in my Google Cloud console
let's start by opening up the cloud
shell editor
editor look at this store
now the first thing that I need to do is
see the search endpoint on Twitter and
query for the appropriate search term
since the search API offers pagination
we need to make multiple APA calls and
collect the results
to handle authentication on the Twitter
API
we make use of Google Cloud secret
manager where the APA keys and secrets
are stored
now that we have called the API fesa
data that we need this part of the
application is complete we should save
the data that we have and terminate this
process
in order to save the data we will use
cloud storage which is a simple and
reliable Object Store
the data can be saved as a Json file
here
one thing to note is that we would like
to keep the tweets and the user
information separate and hence we will
save this into two files one for users
and one for tweets
we've also intimate in state so that we
don't fetch the same tweets over and
over again and for this video data
let's come back to that
this entire processes are quite involved
since it has to handle authentication
imagination has to interact with
multiple services like cloud storage
secret manager database and so on
we will use cloud run to deploy this
part of the application
Cloud analysis serverless container
runtime where I can quickly deploy any
containerized application
so I have written a Docker file for my
application which installs the node
dependencies and starts the node server
the other part of the application which
is equally complex is the leaderboard
paper
in this case I have used BJs and Quasar
framework to build up the web app
again for ease of local development
testing and deployment I have built this
up
this network container in the docker
file that you see we have built the
Quasar application and we are serving
the built web app
we will use cloud run for this aspect
finally before we jump into the
deployment of these applications to
Cloud run we should realize that these
services are important parts of the
application and might undergo frequent
changes and feature additions to help
automate things and make our lives
easier as a developer we can use cloud
build to set up a serverless cicd
pipeline
in Cloud build we can set up triggers to
automate build and deployment
I have a couple of triggers already
created for the two Cloud run services
that we just spoke about I'll go to one
of them
with Cloud build you can set up triggers
where you can listen to events on a
source code Repository in this case I'm
listening to pushes to the main branch
you can even trigger a build only when
files in a specific folder is changed
I will also be using a cloud build yaml
to provide the build and deploy
instructions
now that we have set this up let us take
a quick peek at the cloud build yaml
files that we have been using
here we Define multiple steps
step from building a Docker image
to pushing the image to the Google
artifact registry and then deploying a
cloud run service using this Docker
image we can see that our Cloud run
services are currently empty and let us
manually run the cloud build trigger to
deploy the to Cloud run
we will run the trigger on the main
branch this is the fetch tweets service
and we will run the trigger for the web
app Service as well
typically these would run when code push
is done to the branches in this case I
am triggering this manually
since we want to store the API response
as a Json object for processing later we
can now go into storage buckets and
create a couple of buckets
in this case I already have created two
buckets one for storing the tweets and
the other for storing the users back to
the topic of serverless compute the next
thing we need to do is actually process
the tweets and the user data that we
saved
these processes are lightweight and have
to only read the Json files compute
scores and other relevant statistical
information and save this data into a
database
Cloud functions are ideal for such
simple use cases which move data between
a couple of Google cloud services
we will use the second generation of
cloud functions which is functions as a
service and offers many enhanced
capabilities
I have two such functions here one that
will store the username and user related
information the other that will compute
scores and save that information
since we are building out an even driven
application we are using the functions
framework this is used to define that
this function will handle Cloud events
the cloud even object will contain
useful information about the event
itself which we can then use for further
processing similarly we also have a
couple of apis that will be called by
the web app
the apis and query our database and
return the scores to the web app for
display these are lightweight and we can
use cloud functions to run these as well
since these are apis or web apis we will
be using the HTTP trigger
we can quickly deploy the source code
that we have here as Cloud functions
with just a single Google Cloud
functions deploy command
you notice there is no need for any
Docker files or containerization here
just provide Google Cloud the code and
it will run
I will now deploy these four Cloud
functions
okay so the two apis and the two
functions are going to be deploying in
the background finally last but not the
least we have been talking about saving
data all this while the username data
the score data and some State
information in a database
we will use a highly scalable serverless
nosql document database that is
available on Google cloud and is called
firestore
firestore lets you store data as
json-like documents and offers a
powerful query engine to fetch and work
with the data we can see here in the
data section that the firestore database
is currently empty as a Services begin
to write documents into specific
collection names the collections are
automatically create
and one piece that
we are missing is to actually trigger
this whole process periodically
this is where we will use cloud
scheduler
we have set up a Cron job for every five
minutes using Cloud scheduler
uses Pub sub as one of the targets and
pushes a message to a topic each time
the Quran job is wrong
now that we have all the individual
pieces of our application deployed on
serverless all we have to do is wire
them up using events
let's create those triggers now
so here I am
creating the trigger to
fetch the tweets whenever the Chrome job
runs
this will run when the message is
published we can select the topic to
listen to We Will select the
region where this will run and finally
the cloud runs service
this is for when
Google Cloud Storage resist an event so
when an object is created within a
bucket I also need to specify which
bucket
so in this case let's use tweets
and we will store this course
this is the same on a cloud storage on
finalized
on the user's bucket
and call the store usernames
awesome so our event driven application
is now all wired up and ready to go we
just have to wait for the match to
happen
I'll get it kicked off by manually
triggering a cron run
let's resume the scrounger which I had
paused until now
but we don't need to wait for the next
one we can immediately force a job run
to see that everything is working fine
meanwhile I will go into Cloud run and
check that all our services are
correctly deployed two of them got
deployed through Cloud build and the
other four we deployed through Scripts
let's go into the user bucket
and we see that the user Json file has
just been created
since the file has been created on the
bucket
the next event will be triggered and
here we have the Tweet Json as well
since this has been created the events
will now be sent to the two Cloud
functions that we have which will
process these files and then save the
data into firestore to check that it's
happening we can quickly refresh files
tool itself
and we see that data is being populated
we have both the stores information the
scores information as well as the user
information
this data will be retrieved by the apis
and will be
displayed on the leaderboard
let's go into the
Cloud run Services the leaderboard app
and get the public URL to this app and
there you have it we have the
leaderboard
we have the top 10 scores
we also are able to see per round scores
so with that we have built a
ready-to-use web application with all
the related backend and back-end
services and applications this brings me
to the end of the demo let's jump back
to the slides
all right and here we are
we had a look at the demo that we just
built out to recap the main components
of what we just built in our demo we had
used a couple of services that were
heavy on business logic and we use cloud
run for them one of them was a
background batch process which had to
take care of authentication pagination
managing States Etc we built that out as
a containerized application and used
Cloud built to deploy and manage its
lifecycle the other one was a web app
which had the server side and
client-side dependencies and it was easy
to build that out as a container and
deploy to Cloud run then we had a few
pieces of code that had to only move
data from Object Store to document store
or query data from the document store
wherever the web app requested for it
these were services with simple business
logic that needed to run only on demand
we use cloud functions for these cases
cloud storage was a simple and effective
solution for storing the Json data
especially since it emits an event
whenever a new object is created this
allows us to build reactive applications
cloud firestore is a highly scalable
serverless nosql document database with
Advanced query capabilities and fit the
requirement to store and retrieve scores
and maintain State for the application
finally even talk helped us to easily
wire the entire applications together it
is able to listen to events from
Upstream services and Trigger relevant
Downstream Services whenever needed
without us having to write subscribers
and message handling logic what
application developers want is to
develop and deploy modern highly
scalable Cloud native applications as
quickly as possible with the least
effort on setting up and managing
infrastructure
to achieve this we have used serverless
compute serverless databases and
orchestration uh and and an event
orchestration solution
Cloud run lets you retain the
flexibility to use containers to package
and deploy code and its dependencies
while completely freeing you from having
to do any infrastructure or cluster
management that is required in
containerized workflows Cloud functions
lets you focus on writing the code to
connect with Services Google will take
care of running it scaling it up or down
and serving users on a global scale all
this can be managed using Cloud build
which is a serverless CI CD platform
which enables very fast bills on high
CPU VMS and automates your deployments
we use a serverless document database
firestore which is able to scale up or
down on Demand with its powerful query
engine and support for many popular
languages file store allows one to
easily integrate it into their
applications finally even talk allows
you to easily build even driven
architectures without having to
implement customize or maintain the
underlying infrastructure reliable
delivery and taking the effort out of
having to manage pop subscriptions event
Arc allows you to develop applications
faster where you go from here here are a
couple of Core Labs on even driven
orchestration and serverless that you
can run at your own pace and get
Hands-On with Google Cloud
thank you for joining me have a great
next video
[Music]